wait is my chair too high is it going
down slowly there it is our mean is here
what's up bro thank you for having me
yes sir new album is out it's out mean
yes which means what mean is really what
everybody calls me obviously right I'm
saying it's very autobiographical but I
also figured it'll be an acronym you
know manifest everything avoid
negativity really because I like
manifested this project you know what
I'm saying first of all it's produced by
Scott Storage all of it all of it um
well to be technical there's two songs
on there that Scott Storage didn't do
but he oversaw the whole process his 15
songs two bonus tracks and then 13
records with the last two is not Scott
shout out my boy pyro who did that but
yeah it's basically produced by Scott
Storage
um I work with him the first time it was
like I want to say 2017 or something we
just did like one joint right you know
through Steve Lobel and stuff shout out
to Steve and um I was like man he might
be the one you know I was looking for
that like that production
and I left that session like yo this guy
I don't know how I can get him to do a
whole album because he ain't cheap you
know what I'm saying but I'm like yo
this is the guy for me you know I'm
saying I feel like he has that balance
obviously he's a go producer long story
short it happened you know I mean like a
year and a half two years later
we kind of reconnected through like my
new partners and everything and um they
had a great relationship and they kind
of reintroduced me to Scott like yo
let's not just sell us a beat like this
is really our guy you know I mean in our
community The Armenian and they're like
yo this is really our guy we got his
back and like let's work
and one thing led to another we did the
whole project do you have to pay for all
the Beats not well no one works for free
right you know what I'm saying so but
it's like we gave him a few love we gave
him a fee and just like less work you
know what I'm saying so you didn't you
got you got the the homie rate the super
homey rate super homie because yeah
Scott Storage beats ain't cheap yeah man
that's my dog thank you Scott I
appreciate it yeah but yeah he he also
got excited though once we started
working he's like oh okay like you know
what I'm saying we started really having
records once I finished like the French
joint he was like bro you have a smash
on your hand then I brought Nas to the
studio he's like hold on NAS come into
the studio right you know what I'm
saying so once we started working he
started singing like what I'm doing and
you know what I mean how I'm putting
everything together and he started
respecting it more and more yeah because
the only album you got Nas you got quavo
you got offset right
uh it's a ridiculous track list I got
Nas cuevo offset YG
uh met the man kabaka pyramid shout out
to myth hell yeah shout out to meth that
was the easiest one there's just one dm
and two weeks later it was in my in my
inbox he always showed me love but I
didn't you know I wasn't sure that's
crazy yeah
uh Jeremiah and French
you put the LeBron record on the bonus
yeah yeah the two the two bonus tracks
is King James with Jeremiah and then
y'allah Bibi with French I call it bonus
because I mean they were made during
that process but we had already dropped
them right right right right right right
so you know I kind of put them as bonus
but that King James joint still my
highest stream it don't stop you know I
feel like it it I feel like it's it was
it's like a sync record for like the
playoffs and yeah last last year uh
ESPN synced it yeah he was playing it
during the games you know it's always
like a time limit they they they license
it for like three months is that like
the
the best way to make money off the
actual song outside of streaming is that
I've had some good money off like
um the ESPN one was cool to be honest
but like commercials yeah you can get
your in a commercial that like
plays on a lot yeah um a few Netflix
like TV shows and stuff I've had too in
the past yeah that not only like the
money they pay but um it just brings
awareness you know right like people's
gonna find it online that pops up
on one of your most streamed songs
because people
Shazam it and you know what I mean